so in honor of razer in his love for all
things ball games I'd like to explain
the rules of one of his favorites
volleyball to start off with you
essentially have three basic moves dig
set and subscribe to this channel for
regular Hunter hunter content uploaded
straight into your YouTube feed now with
this knowledge go forth and crush your
enemies in volleyball that is not
literally I was a death row convict too
I killed many people
but Jing hired me and brought me here he
taught me that if just one person in the
whole world believes in you and even you
can be redeemed hello and welcome to
Hunter hunter 101 the series that breaks
down everyone and everything in the
Hunter hunter world and today we are
going to explore the powerhouse game
master of greed island razor razor is a
tall very well-built man generally
observed in what I would call as gym
teacher chic who was first introduced
during the greed island arc he is
betrayed as an ever delightful and
incredibly laid-back person however he
also comes equipped with an
unquestionably ruthless and competitive
nature with a particular penchant for
the game of dodgeball and a lot of those
secondary characteristics bother
dodgeball obsession more than likely
spawn from razor childhood as he was
often physically and verbally abused by
his father calling him things like
slowpoke good-for-nothing loser idiot
etc you get the general gist
however this cause razor to develop an
aggressive inferiority complex which led
him to adopting a life of crime along
with a very very angry persona and
eventually razor grew so violent that he
committed numerous murders however he
would come to be apprehended by a
familiar hunter by the name of Jing
freaks for his crimes razor was
sentenced to death however Jing unlike
anybody and raised his life thus far so
a fair bit of potential in him and
decided to hire razor as part of his
greed island project and this would be a
turning point in the life of razor as up
until now he had only been bombarded
with negative reinforcement however
despite the fact that he was a convicted
criminal Jing frigg's treated razor with
respect as if they was societal equals
and not only that but Jing also
expressed something far more important -
razor which was an innate belief in his
abilities and this new feeling took root
in razor coming to transform him into
the friendly easygoing chap that we know
him as best in the series rather
interestingly it should probably be
noted that Jing treated raised it with
far more of a fatherly hand than he did
with his very own son gong so lucky
razor I guess however Jing would also go
on to give razor
massive job by becoming one of the game
masters of greed island and just a bit
of background on that greed island was a
faux video game developed by Jing and an
array of associates whereby those who
engaged in said game are transported to
a small independent island just east of
the Obion continent and raises main role
in the creation and maintenance of the
game was to ensure the integrity of its
and missive systems which function in
the form of cards that players acquire
which can be materialized into things or
abilities through a simple command of a
player and while the exact
technicalities of what this involves
Razer performing and ever stated it can
be inferred that any card that requires
an emissive ability is done so directly
from the Nana Fraser himself as a result
rather obviously Razer is an emitter
when it comes to the wonderful world of
nan and this is further demonstrated
through one of his signature Honsou
named Dora ball with this technique
Razer omits his aura into a red sphere
and launches it at a target these
condensed balls also contain a
surprising amount of devastating
potential as they have been shown
capable of decimating a person's skull
as well as being able to entirely
destroy a small boat that small boat in
question happened to belong to the
Phantom troupe by the way who initially
arrived on greed Island by sailing to
the location rather than coming through
the fur game and this actually gives us
quite a profound indicator of raises
strength because immediately upon
encountering him Fink's judged his
palette to be tremendous and despite the
fact that he had the large majority of
the troupe behind him thinks reluctantly
accepted raises expulsion from the
island and claimed that they would
return via the proper entrance in doing
so Razer even lay down a slight
challenge to Fink's letting him know
that if he played the game long enough
and he would most certainly have the
opportunity to partake in combat with
him a statement that seems to have
mostly infuriated thinks before Razer
used his abilities to send the entire
troupe to the Asian continent and as
mentioned before Razer must possess a
simply astonishing or output to be able
to facilitate an entire games worth of
the mission mechanics some of which
perform incredibly powerful functions
that would be heavily designed in the
greater world although one possible
explanation for how this may be possible
is the idea of setting strict conditions
and limitations on their abilities
throughout the series we've been witness
to a wide array of examples of nen users
employing these strict conditions on the
activation of their powers thus
increasing the potency of the ability at
the cost of making it harder to perform
in general and what we see here of Razer
male should be a case of that because
the power of the cards can only function
within greed island itself unless of
course you win the game in which case
you are allowed to take a total of three
cards of your choice into the greater
world
furthermore
cards also have a limitation on their
usage so with this restriction noted it
becomes slightly less of a mind-boggling
exercise to speculate on raises exact or
output but with that said it is still an
absolute metric asked ton
however raises skills do not end with
his affinity for a mission as he also
appears to possess quite a mastery in
the area of manipulation which is aptly
demonstrated with the 14 devil's hot
suit this involves raised at creating
eight anthropomorphic nan beasts with
the numbers zero to seven now I know
what you're thinking maybe if he can
only create eight nan beasts then why is
the technique called 14 Devils and well
that's because raises and n beaks are
capable of fusing together to create
stronger and newly numbered forms for
example if B six and seven fused
together then they create beast number
thirteen and I guess it's all very basic
maths from there in any case no matter
what the number of beasts razor is
capable of manipulating them to perform
complex tasks and as for what kind of
complex task those would be well how
about playing dodgeball because in
addition to being a game master razor
also acts as sort of an in-game boss for
Grade Island when trying to acquire the
SS rank card plot of beach in this
challenge a group of players must defeat
razor and his team in eight out of 15
sporting team challenges one of which
being raised a sport of choice very
exceptionally lethal dodgeball and very
notably the only group we're aware of
that has made it to this stage of the
game included gone freaks the son of
Jing freaks now this meeting had
actually been set up far in advance by
Jing who had provided gone with a memory
card for greed island and who had even
tossed Razer to fight with his son with
everything he had yet another example of
Jing's phenomenal parenting at work and
so in the ensuing dodgeball match Razer
puts his incredible skills on display
holding back nothing against gone and
his team which also quite notably
consisted of Kilwa Biscay anti Sokka
so Razer was up against some pretty
serious power himself not that his calm
demeanor would ever let that show that
being the complete tanki is Razer and
his fourteen devil's heart too proved
more than a match for this group and
raising himself even demonstrated that
he was capable of stopping a ball
propelled by the preposterous power of
gongs Jay Junkin technique and during
the match razor began to see great
similarities between Khan and his father
Jing and was particularly impressed by
guns or output at the climax of the game
although it should be noted that in the
end it would be Hisako who clinched
victory against razor as often managing
to reflect Ron's attack he so Kia's
bungee gum to send the ball flying
straight back towards Razer
only this time engaging the hearts who
to make the ball stick to him as well
us forcing Razer out of Bounce I guess
that's a power of both rubber and gum
for you very versatile in any situation
afterwards Razer tells gone that Jing is
not on the island as well as an abridge
life story but he also congratulate
skin' on his victory telling him that he
was instructed to go all-out against the
boy but that he also believes in the
abilities of gone marches Jing had
believed in him all those years ago and
that is rather sadly the last of Razer
that we would see in the series despite
the fact that greed island was no any
over and gone still had to face off
against Ken through and even complete a
quiz to clear the game in fact what
happened to great island in general is a
bit of a mystery and we're forced to
assume that the game still operates with
razer continuously taking care of its
mysterious in mission system some more
fun facts about razer as a game master
of greed island razer also has access to
a special administrator card known as
eliminate this card allows raise it to
banish players who enter the island
illegally to a random location on the
aussie incontinent as for why it can
only banish players to that particular
continent while that's unknown
especially because it's likely not a
case of limitations of nen by distance
as there are at least three continents
closer to the real world location of
greed island then the location specified
on the card in addition to the bulk of
the Phantom troop it is also thought
that Razer used is eliminate card to
expel their leader krohler from the
island although for this to work krohler
would have had to encounter Razer after
the majority of the troop has raised the
States to them that it had been many
years since he had vast had visitors
despite his newfound cheery demeanor
Razer is very much a no-nonsense
individual and takes insubordination
very very seriously and was even willing
to kill one of the other convicts on
greed Island simply for not following
his orders Razer and his fourteen Devils
are actually a reference to a location
called devil city in game battler the
fictional creation in the world of you
Haku sure which toga she was also the
manga qov and quite similarly game
battler required a certain number of
players to band together before being
able to challenge the game master and
finally a truly useless fact when
omitting his aura balls Razer prefers to
launch them using a volleyball spike
very much in stark contrast to how one
would play dodge ball but that pretty
much does it for Razer
if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produced in general
and please do consider donating to the
new world view patreon because the
support of all of you amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video
will like share or subscribe
it also helps plot this channel and
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun at any time then please do
head over to my discord server or a wide
array of shenanigan retakes place on a
daily basis and finally please do
comment with who what or where you'd
like to see featured on the next Hunter
hunter 101
what are your thoughts on the seven
deadly sins anime or manga so I did
really like the seven deadly sins it was
actually a rare series that my wife
brought my attention to actually she got
me to watch the entire first season and
it was great
after that I switched to the manga
briefly and I don't know things is they
didn't quite feel the same I can't
really tell you why because I don't
remember exactly what happened that put
me off I think it was around when bond
went off on his own and things just felt
weird as you probably watch more of it
now though there's much more animated
out there because it was a fun ride at
least in the anime once you cover every
single thing about hunter hunter and ten
years go by and we still don't get
anything new about the series and manga
what would you like to focus this
channel on interesting question
to be perfectly honest I'm not looking
that far ahead not ten years anyway
because I have a feeling that when we
get to that point YouTube probably won't
be a great career option for me or
anyone as copyright law becomes more and
more heavy-handed I think we're going to
see the decline of content like mine I
mean as it is we have about a two year
time period before article 17 is
implemented in Europe which I won't bore
you with the legislation there's plenty
of videos out there if you're keen but
it may very well result in all of my
videos being blocked from the European
Union because YouTube doesn't want to be
liable for any legal issues within those
regions so you know if there was ever a
positive that came with brexit and it
might just be that because the UK may be
exempt from this but even then I think
that the UK will either jump on board or
develop its own legislation and America
will likely follow suit as well leaving
me with the very very serious question
of whether or not I try to convert these
channels into me talking on camera like
most other anime commenters or just
abandon the idea of YouTube altogether
however before then I do hope to cover
everything that Hunter Hunter has to
offer on this channel and if we run out
of content well then that sounds like a
nice future problem to have